public feuds day drinking and sexual
assault with great Fame comes great
entitlement and some of Hollywood's
finests are just downright jerks that's
Kendall Roy on HBO's succession Jeremy
Strong stars in one of the biggest shows
on television burtis's career has been
on a massive upswing his reputation
amongst his fellow actors has taken a
bit of a hit though he rejects the label
himself strong is frequently described
as a method actor phenomenal results can
be achieved by remaining in character in
this fashion but the tactics of method
actors often rub crew members and
castmates the wrong way one notorious
profile on strong in the New Yorker
struck a particularly powerful blow to
his public reputation the profile
revealed that while shooting succession
he was prone to Preparing rehearse
speeches and trying to pass some
Marvel's improvisation as well as
getting inebriated on set when his
character fell off the wagon his
castmates have described his method
acting approach as occasionally
frustrating or intrusive but none have
been more vocally opposed to his habits
than Brian Cox who plays Strong's
on-screen father Logan Roy but during an
interview with Town and Country Cox said
that he thinks strong is a fantastic
actor but that he finds his method
acting style to be annoying succession
is far from the only production where
Strong's method acting has been an
impediment for others on the trial of
the Chicago 7 he frequently ruined the
takes by pulling pranks while in
character as hippie Jerry Rubin and for
one scene he requested to be blasted
with real tear gas even though that
would have meant putting hundreds of
extras and crew members through the same
physical torment Gerard Depardieu is one
of the most celebrated actors in the
history of French Cinema having nearly
250 credits in his filmography over the
course of five decades the party was
played many iconic and acclaimed rails
with such super stardom inflating as ego
he has been known to act as if the rules
didn't apply to him the Pardo committed
pretty crime in his Youth and he's had
plenty of brushes with the law after
becoming a star as well did you steal
still yeah yes of course his scandals
were on the gamut from physical assault
and frequent fighting to white-collar
crimes connected to his numerous
businesses to a weird incident in which
he urinated on a plane we were flying to
Ireland yes that pee on the plane yes
drawing the hashtag metoo movement the
party was accused of sexual assaults by
more than a dozen women most of whom
were actors or crew members who worked
with him as reported by the Associated
Press 13 accusers came out against him
while also suggesting that his total
number of victims was surely much higher
since he had a reputation for frequently
groping and funneling the extras on his
film shoots the party was often been
hailed as one of the greatest actors of
his generation but incredible
performances don't justify his actions
by any stretch of the imagination
Tommy Lee Jones of the four-time Oscar
nominee and one time whenever his role
in 1994's The Fugitive he is known less
for his range and more for his
reliability when it comes to playing
rugged ornery characters the title can
shift from violent and intense such as
in films like the hunted to comedically
slanted as we see in Men In Black
regardless the same core archetype of a
curmudgeon is usually present and as it
turns out this Baseline character type
is close to home for Jones in a 2006
edition of Texas monthly the actor was
profiled in a piece titled Tommy Lee
Jones is not acting which posited that
he really is the rude and grumpy fellow
that he routinely plays on screen he is
known to be incredibly and polite to the
press and the general public and the
behavior extends to film sets when Jim
Carrey appeared on Norm Macdonald life
he recounted his experiences working
with Jones on Batman Forever
he couldn't sanction my buffoonery Toby
Maguire is best known for starring a
Spider-Man in the Sam Raimi Trilogy and
he recently reprized is a role in
Spider-Man and no way home the heroic
morally upright side of the character is
allegedly not one shared by Maguire
personally for many years he actually
has had a reputation for being hard to
work with and extremely Troublesome
behind the scenes his rude out of
control behavior on sets has drawn fire
from his co-stars and his public
Outburst captured by Paparazzi have hurt
his him into the general public Maguire
was one of the only successful Hollywood
stars to be so incendiary in real life
that he became the villain of a woman's
non-fiction autobiography and his
corresponding film adaptation the 2017
film Molly's game tells the true story
of Molly Bloom who ran high stakes poker
games for Hollywood celebrities in the
film Michael Sarah plays an antagonist
who goes by player X he makes it his
mission to destroy Bloom's reputation
and livelihood while also being as awful
as possible to his fellow players at
every turn though the characters true
identity remains unnamed in the movie
Bloom names him outright as Toby Maguire
in her autobiography
Dustin Hoffman has given some of the
best and most influential performances
of all time his roles in films are the
graduates at midnight cowboy were
instrumental in ushering the new
Hollywood movement completely changing
the film industry of the late 1960s and
1970s one of his most acclaimed films
was Kramer vs Kramer in which he plays a
husband who is left in charge of his
young son when his wife leaves him
Hoffman earned his first Oscar win for
the role butcher's methods for achieving
that performance were questionable to
say the least Hoffman was engaging in
hardcore method acting for the role and
took it upon himself to force what he
considered to be a stronger performance
out of co-star Meryl Streep who also won
her first Oscar for the film while
indulging in a frequent improvisation
Hoffman's slapstreep smashed the real
glass against the wall right beside her
head without warning and made low blow
insults about her recently deceased
boyfriend actor John kazal I'm leaving
you honey please
far worse than all of his nasty onset
behavior however other numerous sexual
assault allegations that have been made
against Hoffman a as reported in Forbes
its accusers came into contact with
Hoffman through film shoots and
theatrical performances on Broadway
making working with him in any capacity
an unpleasant proposition
Jennifer Lopez has drawn a claim for
both her music and her acting as well as
for having led a successful career as a
producer the spider Legions of Die Hard
fans Lopez's reputation is far less
Sterling when it comes to those who have
to work with her not just enjoy her
output from a distance she has
frequently been described as difficult
or outright impossible to work with
professionally Lopez has shown a
tendency to lash out at and insult other
celebrities when giving interviews one
of the celebrities are Lopez was most
harsh towards was Cameron Diaz in a now
Infamous interview with a movie line
when the two were cast alongside each
other and What to Expect When You're
Expecting there was obviously a lot of
animosity on set this was far from being
an isolated incident as there are
countless stories over making life
harder for co-stars and crew members and
even members of the general public such
as a hotel maid who she reportedly had
fired for asking for an autograph Lopez
has since denied that claim Laura Flynn
Boyle's big breakout role was on the One
of a Kind television phenomenon Twin
Peaks she played Donna Hayward the best
friend of murder victim Laura Palmer
Boyle starred in both of the show's two
seasons before it was prematurely
canceled by ABC when the prequel movie
twin Pig's firewalk with me was released
just one year after the cancellation
Boyle was no longer involved although
her character still was the recasting of
Donna Haywood with Moira Kelly race fans
suspicions at behind the scenes issues
that led to Boyle's removal from Twin
Peaks especially considering the fact
that she was the only cast member
replaced when the 2017 Revival of the
series Twin Peaks her return finally
came to fruition many years later Boyle
publicly voiced the desire to return to
the series instead Creator David Lynch
purposefully excluded her despite pretty
much everyone else returning her behind
the scenes romances were considered by
some to be a hindrance to the series
according to an AV Club interview with
Cheryl and Fenn she allegedly put a stop
to the planned romance between the Dale
Cooper and Audrey horn characters
because she was dating actor Carl
McLaughlin in real life Boyle had a few
other major roles outside of Twin Peaks
but his word spread of her being
difficult to work with a good rolls
dried up these days her acting gigs are
few and far apart and frequently take
the form of trashy b-movies like Hansel
and Gretel Get Baked Katie Affleck is a
younger brother of fellow actor Ben
Affleck the brothers have worked
together many times over the years but
Katie Affleck's career took a bit longer
to reach the heights of his brothers
Still many film critics considered him
to be the superior actor of the two and
the one who was consistently chosen more
interesting projects his performances
and movies like the assassination of
Jesse James by the coward Robert Ford
and Manchester by the Sea boats Drew
widespread Acclaim and the latter even
earned him his first Oscar win I'm sorry
Lee he passed away about an hour ago as
reported by The Daily Beast Affleck was
accused of sexual harassment by multiple
women including the cinematographer and
the producer of 2010s I'm still here the
accusations led to a pair of lawsuits
that Affleck settled out of court on the
same shoot Affleck partially admitted to
creating an unsafe work environment and
that he was rarely sober throughout the
production according to Guardian he
encourages cast and crew to party with
him as part of the mockumentary
experience
Sean Penn is a five-time nominee and
two-time Oscar winner with many
acclaimed performances and even a few
films as a director under his belt over
the years he has developed something of
a negative reputation the fact that pen
is knowingly embraced in his Oscar
acceptance speech for his performance in
2008's milk Penn said I do know how hard
I make it to appreciate me Penn has also
made it clear on other occasions that he
knows he can be difficult to work with
and even to Simply interact with on a
personal level he has been involved in
many altercations and blow-ups with the
directors of his movies and does not
hesitate at all to voice his opposition
to their creative decisions all of this
without even getting into his Tangled
history of domestic abuse allegations
and violent altercations in the U.S and
abroad and while some of them have been
disputed by all parties involved the
details remain murky Morgan Freeman was
held a reputation as a kind-hearted man
an upstanding member of society and a
role model for all not many actors can
claim to be Typecast as God and does the
go-to default for narration with one of
the most distinctive voices in Hollywood
but after a long and storied career with
a gentle and beloved reputation Freeman
was outed as a prolific Predator
according to CNN the actor was accused
by at least eight women of sexual
harassment and groping on film sets
though the news became public during the
hashtag metoo movement that began in
2017 his pattern of inappropriate
behavior was well known by those in the
industry for years beforehand a crew
member on 2013's Now You See Me revealed
that the woman on the shoot or knew to
expect and welcomed sexual remarks and
touching whenever he was on set they
even collectively decided to wear more
conservative clothing in the hopes of
combating his advances Friedman is also
known to make films huge triangle deals
for the directors he works with even in
some of his most acclaimed roles when
shooting the Shawshank Redemption
Freeman allegedly refused to do
additional takes or follow the scripts
he also forced the big final moments of
the film to be scrubbed and changed
because he considered them as he stated
in an interview at the New York daily
news sort of asinine sort of cliched
sort of unnecessary
foreign
[Music]